gavin además de la escuela tiene dos
trabajos niñera y además trabaja en la
tienda de sus padres trabajando en la
tienda ella recibe un sueldo de 12 pesos
por hora mientras que delinearán recibe
solamente 9 pesos con 50 centavos por
hora la semana pasada ella trabajó 19
horas en total esto me parece muy
importante así que lo voy a poner con un
color la semana pasada ella trabajó 19
horas en total de aquí va a salir una
ecuación y esa semana se llevó 56 pesos
más en la tienda que en su trabajo de
niñera esto también me parece muy
importante cuántas horas se dedicó a
cada uno de sus dos trabajos y bueno lo
primero que hay que hacer cuando tenemos
un problema como estos es definir
variables así que primero vamos a
definir t subíndice n t subíndice en m
es el tiempo que ella le va a dedicar a
hacer linera mientras que t su vil setem
va a ser el tiempo que ella le va a
dedicar a la tienda de sus padres t
subíndice en el subíndice t y lo que yo
sé y fíjate bien aquí voy
usar esta primera oración que subrayemos
esta primera oración me dice que en
total trabajo 19 horas por lo tanto el
tiempo que trabajo siendo dijera más el
tiempo que trabajó en la tienda de sus
padres esto en total nos tienen que dar
19 horas por lo tanto de su 27ma este
subíndice n tiene que ser igual a 19 y
bueno ahora necesitamos otra ecuación y
para sacar la otra ecuación voy a
utilizar esta segunda oración que
subraya pero para esto lo que voy a
necesitar es introducir dos nuevas
variables voy a introducir el pago que
ya recibió siendo niñera le voy a llamar
p subíndice n es el pago que ya recibió
siendo niñera durante toda la semana
pasada es el pago total que ella recibió
siendo niñera y también voy a definir la
variable p subíndice tema que es el pago
que ya recibió trabajando en la tienda
de sus padres esto durante toda la
semana pasada el pago total y por qué
hago esto porque ya te cuentan que esta
segunda reacción lo que me dice es que
ya ganó 56 pesos más
en su trabajo de niñera esto durante la
semana pasada por lo tanto lo que me
está diciendo esta oración es que el
pago que recibió ella en la tienda es
igual a lo mismo que recibió siendo
niñera es decir pe subíndice n más 56
pesos porque recibió ese mismo pago más
56 pesos y ahora ya tengo dos ecuaciones
con cuatro incógnitas o no en qué
problema me estoy metiendo fíjate bien
tenemos cuatro incógnitas dos tiempos y
dos pagos mientras que tenemos dos
ecuaciones cómo podemos resolver este
problema ahora la forma de resolver este
problema va a ser expresando los pagos
cada uno de estos dos pagos totales en
relación al tiempo en el que ya trabajó
en cada uno de sus dos trabajos y de
hecho es justo en este momento en donde
voy a utilizar cuánto gano en cada uno
de sus trabajos por ahora porque date
cuenta ahora sé que la cantidad total
que ella recibió trabajando de dijera
vamos a pensar primero en níger a la
cantidad total que recibió gabi
trabajando de dinero
igual al tiempo que trabaje ella sino
niñera por lo que le pagan a ella por
ahora siendo niñera y si te das cuenta
a ella le pagan 9 pesos con 50 centavos
siento ni era entonces p subíndice en es
igual a la de subíndice n por 950 iba a
funcionar justo igual si nosotros
pensamos en 4 lo que recibió ella
trabajando en la tienda durante toda la
semana
p subíndice tema es igual al tiempo que
trabajo gabi en la tienda es decir te
subís setem por lo que gana ella por
ahora en su trabajo en la tienda es
decir por 12 y fíjate que esto tiene
toda la lógica del mundo porque si ella
trabaja tres horas en la tienda me
quedaría 3 por 12 y entonces ella en
total ganaría 36 pesos y si ya trabaja 2
horas siendo niñera entonces sería 2 por
9.50 lo cual son 19 pesos y estoy
haciendo estas igualdades porque ahora
voy a sustituir peso bindi cn y peso 27
en esta ecuación que tengo aquí en lugar
de poner p subíndice n&p subíndice te lo
que voy a hacer es sustituir lo que
valen estas variables
términos del tiempo es decir 9.50 por el
tiempo en lugar de peso 15 ene y por
otra parte en lugar de p 27m 12 por el
tiempo que ella trabajó en la tienda y
entonces que me va a quedar 9.50 por
'the subíndice n más 56
esto tiene que ser igual ap subíndice
tema pero p subíndice tema es lo mismo
que te subíndice por 2 es decir 12 por t
subíndice te yasin ya tengo aquí dos
ecuaciones con solamente dos incógnitas
y logré tener un sistema de ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas trabajando en esta
sustitución de estas variables que tengo
en pie la derecha y ahora sí sí tengo 25
ventas y dos ecuaciones cómo resuelve
este sistema de ecuaciones pues es
momento de utilizar el álgebra tengo dos
ecuaciones y dos incógnitas y se me
ocurre que de esta ecuación de que
arriban lo que voy a hacer es despejar
alguna de las dos variables para
utilizar el método de sustitución y me
queda que te subí de cn más te su 27mo
es igual a 19 y si yo resto opte
subíndice de ambos
de la ecuación estos dos se van y me
queda que este subíndice n es igual a 19
menos este subíndice está perfecto ya
tengo que te subíndice en es igual a 19
menos te subíndice t por lo tanto ya lo
puedo sustituir aquí en lugar de ponerte
subíndice n voy a poner 19 - te subís de
ese tema es el método de sustitución
solamente que con muchos subíndices y
bueno que me va a quedar 9.5 por ley
subíndice n de subíndice en m es
exactamente igual que 19 menos este
subíndice tema entonces me quedan 9.5
por 19 menos de su 27 más 56 esto tiene
que ser igual a 12 que multiplica ate
subíndice t y bueno ahora hay que hacer
9.5 por 19 9.5 por 19 lo voy a hacer
aquí porque realmente yo no me sé la
respuesta de esta multiplicación así que
vamos a hacerla a mano
9.5 por 19 es lo mismo que 19 por 9.5 5
por 945 y llevamos 4 y después 5 por 154
son 9 después pongo aquí un 0 no lo
olvidemos y me quedan 9 por 981 llevamos
8 9 por 19 + 8 son 17 y ahora sí vamos a
sumar todo esto aquí me queda 5 aquí me
queda 10 llevamos 1 aquí es 8 y este uno
se va acá entonces recorre el punto
estiman un lugar y me queda 180 puntos
59 punto 5 por 19 es 180 punto 5 después
9.5 por 1 me queda menos 9.5 por tes uvr
index detem más 56 esto tiene que ser
igual a 12 te subíndice te muy bien
tenemos una ecuación con solamente una
incógnita y entonces para resolver esto
es lo que voy a hacer primero es sumar
180 puntos cinco más 56 lo cual me dan
180 me queda 230 230 y 6.5
236 punto 5 - 9.5 ttm - 9.53 humilde [ __ ]
esto tiene que ser igual a 12 de
subíndice tema de subida systems y ahora
voy a sumar 9.5 de ambos lados de la
ecuación para que éste se vaya del otro
lado entonces más 9.5 t su 27mo y del
otro lado más 9.5 este subíndice de 9.5
te brinde st.george y vamos a sumar esto
y esto de tal manera que del lado
izquierdo me queda solamente 200 36.5
mientras que del lado derecho no queda
12 más 9.5 y esto multiplicado por tres
su 27
esto es 21.50 subíndice t y ahora sí
divido todo entre 21.5 voy a encontrar
el resultado de el tiempo en el que gaby
trabaja en la tienda por lo tanto vamos
a dividir todo entre 21.5 todo entre
21.5 de tal manera que estos dos se van
y el tiempo en que gaby trabaja en la
tienda es exactamente igual a 236
5 entre 21 y vamos a hacerlo también a
mano 21.5 va a dividir a 236 puntos 5
236 punto 5 recorremos el punto decimal
un lugar entonces éste va para cam y por
lo tanto este también va para cam y me
quedan 215 me va a dividir a 2.365
entonces primero tomo esto de aquí me
queda una vez aquí pongo 215 y voy a
restar estos dos y me queda 6 menos 5 s
16 menos 5 o si siempre es 1 y después 3
- 1 es 2 entonces me quedan 21 aquí bajo
un 5 es otros son iguales entonces ya la
hice porque entonces pongo aquí un 1 y
aquí me queda 215 estos dos se van y se
acabó
perfecto ya quedó ya sé que ella trabaja
en la tienda 11 horas y si trabaja en la
tienda 11 horas cuántas horas va a
trabajar gabi siendo niñera pues bueno
date cuenta que aquí podemos sustituir
este valor y en lugar de este subíndice
te voy a poner 11 y me queda que el
tiempo que ya trabaja haciendo niñera es
19 menos 11 lo cual son 8 horas ella
trabaja siendo niñera 8 horas y perfecto
ambos tiempos suman 19 y tú puedes
verificar con calma la segunda ecuación
por el momento es todo nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo